the Joe Rogan experience he tells me I
follow on Instagram I find him
fascinating so shows me these girls with
giant butts that's he knows a bus no
real ones real ones real job you can
tell them not because of the diaper but
Draper butt is our thing that looks real
that's real it's [ __ ] dude Jesus Christ
that makes me uncomfortable it's hot in
here
you know what's here's a fascinating
thing the ass was not a big deal for a
long time for a long time you go back to
like Lynda Carter and Wonder Woman you
never saw her ass ever an ass was not a
thing man
yeah ask Farrah Fawcett you never saw
Farrah Fawcett's ass right no but now if
a girl's gonna be a hot chick she's got
to have a banging ass
yeah but girls like in a movie as a hot
chick yeah there's gonna be a point in
the movie where you see her in a pair of
tight jeans you go whoa
Yeah right yeah the next slot set that
like we needed big butts I like big
butts it was definitely a moment but
always in the Mexican community and the
black community we were always into big
butts we didn't need we didn't need
society to tell us that we didn't know
what the hell was we're just like I
think if scientist grandpa's in the
future and they're studying the size of
asses they'd be like well this
unnoticeable jump in women's asses a
certain point time in the 20th century
look what is that I saw this documentary
once called the history of sex it was on
the Science Channel or something was a
five-part documentary and they were
getting into why we we like certain
things from the opposite sex and the but
apparently the reason well obviously
like tits we like tits if they're big
like we'd like them because you know
baby they're gonna be able to feed the
baby right so we get endorphin rush big
because woman can have birth give birth
easier so you're attracted to that
symmetry according to this documentary
the fat in the butt during the third
trimester of pregnancy
see that's when the brain develops and
and the brain is developed from fat from
the ass according to this documentary so
I guess we're looking at big round asses
first smarter babies evolutionary that's
what the documentary said I don't you
know who knows it well they definitely
know the shape of a woman that's
attractive to us because that's the most
fertile women the women that's gonna be
most likely to hold a baby to term and
raise the child and that's why all those
qualities that you like in him like what
a lot of men are really attracted to
nurturing women and you really attracted
to a woman who wants a cookie dinner
you know a woman who wants to like give
you a massage like to a lot of guys
that's a big deal because that's like a
nurturing type woman that would be not
just that way to you but that way to
your children too we're talking about
why scientifically our men into we're
also talking about how back in the day
asses weren't a big deal with Farrah
Fawcett you never saw Farrah Fawcett's
ass
Wonder Woman Marilyn oh yeah nobody
wasn't sticking around all right
curvy though what you know where might
have happened you know what Jayla amber
Vita Guerra yeah before they miss but
she was famous just for her ass that's
true just for ASP with no internet yeah
no internet dude magazines everybody
knew who she was
Guerrero the all-time ask queen yo this
was pre-internet right pre-social media
she's like that son get Best Buy ass at
a [ __ ] out of Dodge with that ass and
that was and it was DNA and earned that
wasn't he's a human or something shot
yes exactly she was I know a guy I know
a guy fat and stuff and I know I'm to
her and he was he was not into her well
I am I
he just likes dudes he says just there
was nothing to talk about with a man
sometimes I mattress talk with her
sometimes you just wanna have a
conversation bro and snuggle she's a
singer too hey dude well sometimes she
put on an album
you know sometimes it with a gal you
give her a book and say hey before we do
anything physical you read this and I
want to read it and it was talk let's
talk about the book
dude she that was a great [ __ ]
reference to her I forgot about Vita
Graf she was my favorite I had a poster
of my college dorm loved her so what's
impressive is her ass superseded the
Internet it like bypass she sure was
before the end I think it was wasn't it
was there but it wasn't why she got
famous she got famous magazine zero she
was in lowriders for sure she she had a
push from the internet there was dude's
past and her picture around and she'd
been way bigger if she was current now
well yeah what I should say is well
there's a lot of girls like her now
she'd get lost in the shuffle what I'm
saying is like then she was one of the
few girls that people would pass her
photos around pre social media correct
so it wasn't like it was like this girl
on an Instagram page and she had ten
million followers because of her ass it
was like guys like you would go dude
look at this and you would send it to me
and I'd go Jesus I hung a poster that
was born people emailed each other the
FHM maxim what years later he's probably
done five hundred Meg's thousand five
this is pre so she dating Nicolas share
some [ __ ] myspace time but that wasn't
the same as like Twitter Facebook I
thought she had a tremendous myspace
right Oh probably she probably did more
lucious do you think she had Tom right
in the upper left-hand corner [ __ ]
top eight or whatever it was she's still
relevant on Instagram now she all old
were and whether door she liked or she's
like yeah well it's home girl's name
who's the dimepiece who's on Modern
Family
oh she's still killing it she still
looks good congratulations yeah I'm not
mad at her I'm oh hey let's see if you
find an actual there it is
Oh still straw still doing it girl
strong strong game oh she's got some
that's some DNA that's from the
motherland I don't know where the
motherland is but wherever it is that's
from the river she's from that's another
one she tapped into that [ __ ] like maple
syrup God
donkey didn't she date someone really
famous I hope so doin good 40 still
doing it what send this with her okay
not God you say it was hot earlier dude
doughnuts
I'm feelin all weird fellas funky sorry
dude so we got through this she's gonna
have a million followers after this
podcast people though she is this is our
first fight companion other than
kickboxing outside the UFC that's right
man it's good okay sorry about the
nucleus or sorry
there we go those bumps are real
[Applause]